-Our next guest
is a talented actress
who stars in the new romantic
comedy "I Want You Back,"
which premieres February 11th
on Prime Video.
Please welcome Jenny Slate!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my bud! Oh, my buddy!
So good to see you, Jenny.
Jenny Slate.
-Hi, Jimmy. Hi.
-Jenny,
I'm so happy to see you.
I just wanted to say
congratulations.
You're married. You have a baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How is the baby?
How is it all going?
-It's going -- I think - I mean,
you will have to ask her,
although she can't talk yet,
but I think it's going well just
in terms of how we're vibing,
I feel like.
-What is she into now?
What's the new thing?
-What she's into now is jokes.
She likes --
She likes my comedy, but --
I know. My comedy
has become comedy for babies.
Like, the hit around this house
is I take her pacifier.
I just did it, by the way,
for my friends.
I go, "Can I try this?"
And she's like, "Eh."
And I'm like,
"Is it spicy? Is it spicy?"
And she's like, "Eh."
And then I put it in my mouth,
and I'm like -- [ Groans ]
And then I kind of,
like, spit it out,
and that's apparently
the best work I've ever done.
-[ Laughter ]
-That's a good bit.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about
your wedding because,
again, congratulations.
But I know it was pushed a bunch
of times because of the pandemic
and then you were just like,
"You know what?
We're going to do it.
I don't care. We're doing it."
You got married in your home.
-We got married
on New Year's Eve
after four other times
of trying to get married.
We got married
in the living room.
And there were 23 people.
It was -- It was a small affair.
We weren't -- Like it or not,
we weren't able to get a refund
on a lot of the things
that we booked
when we thought we were
going to have like 200 people.
So we had the flowers
that you would have
for like a 200-person wedding
but for 23 people.
So it was very decadent,
I think, yeah.
-You brought us a photo,
which --
Thank you very much
for doing this.
Look at you guys here.
How cute is that? Come on.
[ Audience awws ]
That is just -- Come on.
And was the baby --
Did the baby partake
in the wedding at all?
Was she part of the wedding?
-You know, it was
a tight guest list, as I said.
-[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
Wow!
You didn't even invite the baby.
Alright. Understood.
Yeah, I mean, hey --
That's another plate
right there, yeah.
-Just like, you know,
"I just met you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We got married
in between snack time
and dinnertime for the baby,
and so she was there.
And then -- And we got married,
and, like,
it was just very few people,
but I still wore
a beautiful gown.
Like, kind of
one of the fanciest things
I've ever worn in my life
to make, you know,
like, the walk up "the aisle"
from my bedroom
to the corner
of the living room.
-Yeah.
-But, like, after a while,
it was time to put the baby
to sleep, and so, like,
I left the wedding in my gown
to put the baby to bed,
like, gave her the bottle
and put her to bed.
Like, if any parents
are out there,
you know that once the baby
is asleep you are just like,
"Please don't --
Just please stay asleep
for just a little bit,
just a little bit."
-Yeah.
-And on my wedding night --
Again,
I wouldn't have imagined this.
I crawled on my hands and knees
out of the baby's room,
like, in my very fancy dress.
-"Everyone be quiet."
-And as I passed by --
And someone was being loud
in the bedroom next door.
My friend's kids
were watching "The Hobbit."
And I, like, opened the door
still on my hands and knees
and was like,
"Turn 'The Hobbit' down!"
And I was just like --
On my wedding night,
you know, I don't think I would
have imagined just yelling
"Turn 'The Hobbit' down."
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
That's interesting.
You can't predict this stuff.
-You can't.
You just --
You just got to stay romantic.
-Yeah.
-And stay hopeful.
-How about that for a segue?
Let's talk about your romantic
comedy called "I Want You Back."
It's you and Charlie Day,
who is unbelievably funny.
What a great dude.
He is so funny.
-What a gentleman. Yeah.
-You guys have great chemistry.
Have you worked together?
-I think we do.
-Have you done stuff together?
-Thank you for saying so.
Yeah, he's a real class act.
I met him before we shot.
But right before we -- Ten weeks
before we made the movie,
I had my daughter.
So I met him and I was like
nine months pregnant,
wearing these, like, gigantic
overalls, and I was like,
"You'll be falling in love
with me, you know."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm the girl of your dreams.
I'm super pregnant."
And then I really
got to know him on set,
and he truly is, like,
such a class act.
He's a comedy star,
but also just what a darling.
-Can we set up the movie at all?
-Sure.
Yeah.
Sure, I know what it is about.
I was in it. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-I play a character named Emma.
Charlie plays Peter.
We have both been dumped
at the beginning of the movie.
And we meet while we are crying
in a stairwell, separately.
And then we notice
each other crying,
and then we decide to support
each other through our sadness,
and that quickly turns
into hatching a scheme
to try to get our exes back
for each other.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Jenny Slate
in "I Want You Back."
Take a look at this.
-What about this?
It's a good plan. Hear me out.
-Mm-hmm.
-How about whenever
we are feeling like
we really have to call them
and we just can't
take it anymore...
-Mm-hmm.
-Instead of calling our exes,
let's call each other.
-Hmm! I love that!
-Yeah?
-I love it because we're
intercepting each other's heads.
-Yes.
-Yes! We're each other
sadness sisters.
-Well, "sadness sisters" sounds
like you're Diane Keaton
and I'm Meryl Streep
and we're in a Broadway play,
but I like it, yeah.
-That's a great cast.
You should cast plays.
-Yeah, you should cast plays.
Jenny Slate, everybody.
"I Want You Back" premieres
February 11th on Prime Video.
So happy for you, bud.